I'm apostle Michael Patton I am the
president of your local South Bend in
double ACP our board of directors are
delighted to be here on today to be a
part of this city town-hall gathering
and we want to be engaged and we are
involved in every speck of the meaning
of that that we are have our hands in
the process of what's taking place and
we're looking forward to creating
solutions and be being a part of
bringing healing to our community as
well we also have with us mayor Pete
Buddha judge would you give him a round
of applause as he's joined us as well we
have our chief of police chief scott
Rakowski would you give him a round of
applause I saw also many of the council
members they are present if you will
stand wherever you are we would
appreciate that they are front and
center thank you as well and there are
many other community leaders let me
recognize the pastors in the community
the faith community if you would stand
if you are a pastor in this community
please stand with me
we solicit your prayers pastors and as
well all of the people of God as we're
walking through the process of this
gathering as well we certainly solicit
the prayers of those that are present
we're now going to ask mayor Pete Buda
just to come and as well give us an
overview thank you and thank you to
apostle patent for hosting and
moderating thank you to Washington High
School for having us thank you to
everybody for caring enough to be part
of this we are here for several reasons
we're here first and foremost because
the city is hurting because the city is
in pain because someone among our number
died at the hands of another person in
this city we're here to share
information or here to respond to
questions and we're here to make
progress not because we think we can
solve everything here or or solve
everything at all but because we know
that we'll be one step closer if people
have the right information
and if people are heard
a couple things I should admit that I
cannot speak to today first of all I
cannot speak to whether any of the
actions on Sunday by mr. Logan or by any
of the officers involved were legal or
illegal because that is being
investigated separately similarly I
cannot speak to whether any actions by
any officers at that time were in
accordance with policy or against policy
because that is going to be reviewed in
a separate investigation those
investigations have to be impartial and
just and transparent I will do nothing
to prejudice them I will say that we
will deal with the findings when they
come
I know how much concern there is in this
city over the police involved shooting
that happened last Sunday there's also a
lot of concern around this city over the
loss of life that took place early this
morning in our city ten people were shot
at least one life has been lost every
time a civilian dies at the hands of an
officer every time a civilian dies at
the hands of another civilian and any
time an officer comes to hand harm at
the hands of the civilian they are all
disasters there's a disaster for the
family every single time we were
actually on track as a city to have less
shootings than last year and last year
had less shootings in the year before I
certainly not true as of this moment
we can't bring that number down without
all of us doing something about that and
I know this is part of that we're
bringing together people who care about
safety and justice and believe that we
can and must have both I want to share
very briefly the process that is going
on there will be more to discuss as the
questions come in that there is one
process for reviewing whether any laws
were broken on Sunday that is in the
hands of the Metro homicide unit that
another process will take place that is
for whether any discipline of any
officer is called for that will be in
the hands of the department and will
then go to the board of safety I've
heard the community expressed two things
about the process that I just want to
make clear right away where our
administration is the first is a desire
for an outside look at what has taken
place here by the US Department of
Justice
I recognize that requests I respect it I
will send a letter to the Department of
Justice Civil Rights Division expressing
that the city agrees I cannot promise
that they will act on it secondly the
community has expressed concern about
the review underway by Metro homicide
because even though it is separate from
the South Bend Police Department it of
course involves local law enforcement
some in the community have asked for an
independent investigator to be appointed
by the prosecutor to take over I don't
want to let you know that I agree with
this recommendation as well and that I
notified the prosecutors that I would
like for him to take that
[Applause]
it is his decision but I have let him
know that I would like for that to
happen and shared some of the reasons
why we're not only here because of what
happened Sunday even though that is
obviously what has brought us to this
point there is a lot beneath the surface
when it comes to trust and legitimacy
around policing and race in our city
there's a lot of things we've done and I
just want to make sure I've named them
the institution of bias training civil
rights training community policing
efforts that have been going on for
years
transparency online and if you're not
familiar with it I would urge you to
consult the South Bend police
transparency hub online it's a website
with information policies data and if
anyone has any suggestions about
additional data sets to add those will
be taken seriously we've acted to have a
more professional promotions process and
to raise discipline standards which as
you may know have included officers
being removed from the force for
misconduct we've also taken efforts for
diversity recruiting to make sure that
the department resembles the community
it serves and is more diverse and have
implemented body cameras as the mayor of
the city I want to acknowledge that
those last two lines of effort the
effort to recruit more minority officers
to the police department and the effort
to introduce body cameras have not
succeeded and I accept responsibility
for that we have tried but not succeeded
to increase diversity in the police
department and we need help
and while body cam cameras were
implemented across the department
obviously there is enormous frustration
which I share that they were not there
when we needed the most and there will
be action on that too
so I'll keep this brief so we can get to
the questions I just want you to know
that we're not running from this we're
going to have a conversation that I hope
will be respectful I hope that everyone
who speaks may speak without
interruption and I hope that I know that
people are gonna walk out of this room
satisfied I understand that we are here
to have tough conversations but I want
everyone here at least to be empowered
and I want to make sure voices are heard
that's why we're here and so I'm gonna
stop talking and go over there our
moderator will ask some questions and
then we will move to audience questions
after that and again I thank you for
being here and I thank everyone who is
here to respectfully participate in this
conversation
Thank You mayor Pete for giving us the
overview I want to ask that we would be
respectful to this process we have a lot
of information and content to share and
so as we respect you from this area
please respect us as well we're going to
do our very best to get your questions
answered and share information with you
that I believe will be empowering on
today and so let's walk in loved one
took one towards another can you look at
your neighbor and say let's walk in love
one to another thank you so much I
appreciate the respect that you're
giving me at this time
[Applause]
the Bible says love never fails and love
will cover a multitude of sin and so
let's walk in love one to another so
that we can have a healthy engagement
this is a time that we can communicate
one to another we're all hurting
including myself you feeling me we're
all hurting including myself I've got
questions myself that need to be
answered and I'm here to help facilitate
those questions that we have pre-made
and then those questions that will come
from the audience and so we're looking
forward to your participation as well as
the N double AC president I think it's
important for you all to know that we
are a advocacy organization and we are
at the table because we believe in fair
and equitable equitable processes and
we're believing that justice will come
out of this as you give us time through
the process I'm emphasizing that for a
reason because nothing's going to happen
in the next 36 hours but there's a
process to this and we want to give it
time to unfold so that we can address
the challenges that are before us all
right with that being said let's get
started with the questions to our mayor
and to our Chief of Police first
question is what happens after an
officer involved what happens after an
an officer-involved shooting
chief Scott well that's kind of a big
questions but from the scene itself
Metro homicide is immediately clock the
call they come to the scene and we
relinquish the scene those officers that
are unseen whoever the the commander's
or supervisors are relinquish that scene
to Metro homicide
Metro homicide does what they do with
any other investigation which is to
transport witnesses down and whoever may
be involved and take statements at the
Metro homicide unit immediately our cell
been officers unless they're involved in
an actual incident will not be part of
the investigation
Metro homicide with its Mishawaka and
st. Joe County officers would be
involved in that investigation and now
South in the process with the from the
investigative perspective is
self-explanatory where they would go and
give statements and they would ask
questions etc but the evidentiary
portion would be on those crime-scene
technicians that would go out there and
process the scene whatever that scene
may be and from from that point on it's
it's an actual scene that we would do
not the South Bend Police Department but
they would do what we would process
similar and any crime scene that we
would have so it is treated as a crime
scene from that perspective once once
that is done all the statements all the
evidence all the facts are obtained that
is presented to the prosecutor the
prosecutor then makes a decision on
whatever that result may be we do not
have consultation with with the
prosecutor and whatever his decision is
is what his decision is that information
facts evidence statements etc is handed
over to us afterward we internally
compare all those facts evidence
statements etc to our internal policies
but we still ask other questions on top
of that there's a difference there's
Miranda when the officers are down
talking to Metro homicide that's
involved which means the right to remain
silent and all of those things on the
police department side that is not the
case you are compelled to give testimony
regarding policies and procedures about
our policies and procedures if you
refuse to do so then you can be
terminated separa I'm sorry if from that
point then a recommendation is made
based on those policies and procedures
and it is written out and we present
that I do make a recommendation to the
board based on any violations of any or
all of those policies and procedures
that may come into play that goes to the
board of Safety and the board of safety
would make the ultimate decision based
on my recommendation they they can agree
with my recommendation or they can
exceed my recommendation but it's based
on a period of time of that
recommendation for example a letter of
reprimand all the way determination
every
time goes to the board of safety so they
review that however a letter of
reprimand up to five days does not
require a hearing the board is still
notified in the end the board still
obviously looks on that and they and
they put signatures on that the officer
can still ask for a hearing even within
that letter of reprimand to five days
and the board could if they wanted to
have a hearing but that's that's that's
the Board's decision I do not have an
influence it's only a recommendation
from from my part meeting the self and
Police Department to the board anything
six days and over whether or not the
officer asked the board gives us as I
decide whether they have a hearing out
or not or rely on my recommendation and
I think these materials have been
circulated does everybody have some
paper that's gone around so okay we'll
try to will try to circulate more copies
if we run out one of them is a flowchart
explaining what chief just described I
know it's a little confusing the second
is the state law just want to make sure
this is well understood the the
procedure for an officer being
disciplined or terminated is set in the
state law and it's sets that the board
of safety has that authority you can
sort of think of it like a trial so in
the same way that if you or I were
accused of a crime there would then be a
process in court if an officer is
accused of misconduct there is a process
before the board which then makes a
decision about discipline or termination
thank you gentlemen
question for you as well we understand
you get it you're part of the process
but it's still a little hairy to me and
I'm sure to our audience what does that
look like are we talking 30 days we're
talking 12 months is this a 20 24 month
period can you share that with us yes
thank you apasa I'm glad you brought
that up we there still was a contractual
obligation with the police department
via the board of Safety and via the
Common Council that the FOP which is
essentially a union within the police
department these are members that they
have a contra
actual agreement with our city of what
things - and these are like days off
working hours things of that nature
their working conditions essentially but
within them there are things like their
Bill of Rights and there's things that
that they have through contract
negotiations came up with an agreement
with with everybody within the city so a
minimum of an investigation is 60 days
however we've strived to have it done
within all investigations done within 30
days but that's based on circumstances
based on evidence based on severity
based on many things
now contractually we have to have an
investigation done no more than 60 days
unless there's extenuating circumstances
then I would have to notify the officer
and city legal and everyone else of the
reasons for those extensions and they
have to be legitimate reasons for those
extensions please would you respect the
process I've asked you to respect the
process we're walking in love one
towards another have I yelled at you I
would not want you to yell at me
[Applause]
that's quite me anxiety please ma'am
that's quite me anxiety thank you so
much all right here we are let's talk
about where we are in the process of the
investigation and so chief Scott if you
begin with that process and then mayor
Pete if you were then as well add into
that where are we in the process of this
investigation right now to my
understanding Metro homicide is still
doing whatever they are with facts and
evidence I don't know it's been
presented to the prosecutor for his
review yet I have no knowledge of that
and I certainly don't want to speak in
on behalf of the prosecutor I can only
speculate maybe waiting on results or
fingerprint comparisons or DNA or things
of that nature again that's only my
speculation I don't know in that process
and again I don't want to speak for the
prosecutor let me say this you have an
idea of some things that have happened
thus far the prosecutor came out on
Monday and explain some things to us so
we know that we've gotten that first
little bit of information but we also
recognize there's more to come can you
address that so that people understand
not so much I guess exactly where we are
in the process but there has been some
information shared yeah would it be
accurate to say that in the past these
things have taken in two days to a few
weeks yes the one thing I would mention
is of course if it gets referred to an
outside schirra Secutor that will add to
the amount of time but I think my sense
is that that would be worth accepting
that okay thank you for your answers so
how does the police department know if
cameras are being used in accordance to
police regulation as I oppose that
question is obvious our audience is
aware that cameras were not used on
Sunday June 16th it sounds as though
the officer who fired his weapon did not
have his camera on and as well possibly
those who came to support that shooting
as well may not have had their cameras
on can the two of you addressed that
when is it that cameras are supposed to
be used and based upon the police
regulation so let me start and I've
received a lot of questions and texts
and everything from people one thing I
want to clarify Apostle is people kept
asking me what what should meant in the
policy and should means you will turn
the camera on unless you have a
compelling reason not to okay so that
part first so the second part the first
part of your question is the second part
of your the first part of your question
is please every please we're trying to
be informed every pursue every use of
force we are please let's walk in love
one to another we're walking the process
out thank you so much thank you so much
we're walking the process out so chief
would you continue on every pursue every
use of force is reviewed just not from
the ocean like a pursuit for example if
somebody's involved in a pursuit we
don't just look at the vehicles the
squad cars are the actions of the
officers camera or car that were
involved in the pursuit sure but even
those of responding to the pursue it
maybe could be on the other side of town
or whatever we reach them as well the
same thing with use of force if I could
add the the text of the policy is on
that police website I'm the transparency
hub that I mentioned so if anybody wants
to read the words of the policy so the
policy was developed based on a best
practice group with called LexA pole and
I also want to mention the chief that my
request put out a general order last
week reminding officers
our expectation that the camera is
operating during any interaction with a
civilian in the course of work and I
want to make clear that in the view of
the administration that is not a change
in policy that is a statement of our
understanding of the policy as with any
policy if there is a determination that
any officer did not follow the policy
then that would be subject to a
disciplinary process all right thank you
so much for the responses to that
question as well so what action is taken
when this procedure is not followed in
other words where is the accountability
here chief so again it depends on
circumstances of officers and we've had
occasions where officers have left the
cameras rolling the entire time even
when they're using facilities if they're
if there is if there's an issue and
we're made aware of it should look into
that
absolutely so it's if it's a first
offense for example it could be a
counseling performance improvement plan
it could be verbal reprimand or it could
be up to a letter or higher to the board
of safety again based on the severity in
the reasons that it was not as a
compelling reason why they were not
turned on so we're going to have a
question and answer time for the
audience please we're going to get there
just let us walk through the process
please I appreciate it
so so when there's nothing so when
something doesn't occur in regards to
those cameras being turned on there's no
there's nothing in place that lets you
or the supervisors know that the cameras
are being operated on a daily
okay thank you so much for your
responses next question who can fire a
police officer so that's the Board of
Public Safety
so under and I want to make sure this is
understood this is important under
Indiana law the chief cannot fire a
police officer under Indiana law the
mayor cannot fire a police officer
here's how for any reason so
let's be respectful of the mayor's time
thank you the mayor had taken a moment
out of his schedule to come and listen
and and to let's be respectful and to
share with you the process of how our
city government operates so please
please let's be respectful mayor Pete
Neal yes okay sure sure so so let's one
last question for mayor Pete and chief
Scott how will you keep the community
informed in regards to this process how
will we do that moving forward so it's a
very difficult process to do to even
conceive because again when it comes to
law legalities contract it's it's
difficult to give information out
however and and I've heard this and I'm
glad you mentioned this when officers
please booze cannot be released except
for court order or subpoena or if the
officer any officer so say for example
an officer left the police department
and they say how they were wrongly done
and I'm just giving an example have that
officer give me permission in writing to
release their internal affairs file and
you can look at them okay
mayor Pete so so let's allow for our
mayor now to answer the question thank
you so much so our intention will be to
release as much information as we
legally can as quickly as possible
so as you know there are moments
there will be someone with the mic where
that's going to be who's going to handle
the mic for questions or are we allowing
them to come to the stage
have a microt question
yeah are we wanting them I think there's
a lower IQ of the state should be a
microphone in the audience microphone
will come to you know
do we have one in the audience again
okay a microphone will come to you
thank you for your patience a mic is now
coming let me say as well that we do
have the National Action has joined us
as well Reverend Al Sharpton and his
team is here on tonight
and so we're appreciative to their
presence as well they are coming with a
mic and we are still awaiting the mic so
that each individual who wants to ask
questions will be able to as well
articulate themselves here we go
all right we now have the mic and let me
thank everyone for your presence and I
hear the uproar in the pain I'm getting
ready to introduce myself
my name is pastor Carlton Lynch I serve
with Reverend Al Sharpton nationally has
her network so yeah yes ma'am yes ma'am
yes ma'am
all all we're coming to do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the craftsman yet now all of a sudden is
their narrative
how's that be met by me personally
didn't get my ideas stores just the fact
that the community we stopped taking peg
for us to reach out reach this gap or
whatever else and we reached out to them
and they said no
good afternoon everyone my name is Shari
and I serve as the director to the
outreach I thank you for coming here
today this is my alma mater this is my
home so if we can allow us that comes to
you to put the mic to you so that way
it's a safe and productive conversation
I would greatly appreciate that if
that's okay
[Applause]
[Music]
and also if I made because I don't we
have a lot of questions you want to make
sure we get to those questions and get
to a place where people can share their
grievances what a blue if we can do two
minutes if that's possible to want to
make sure that people get a chance to
have their voice heard and given space
to listen thank you so much thank you
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I don't understand how you expect anyone
to talk about respect and they don't
press society
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
make them do paperwork put the people
that care about the fact that you
different than me honey I love your hair
make them the ones out there on the
streets thank you ma'am thank you may I
respond to that for just a second let me
respond to that you might stay around
just blonde respond responding you go
back to your seat okay first of all
thank you for that and I appreciate that
what you said is specific and actionable
and constructive I will say that if
anyone who is on patrol is shown to be a
racist or to do something racist in a
way that is substantiate it that is
their last day on the street and I would
love to be able to finish I would love
to be able to finish my reply if that's
okay
I would appreciate being able to finish
my reply I believe you have described a
specific tool that can be used in order
to identify indications of racism it is
not familiar to me and so I thank you
for bringing it up and I will research
it right away